do you see me stops  he's backing up  [Music]  uh-oh  [Music]  oh call the police  now call them multiple people please no  you know the you know those brutal  people who are slaughtering innocent men  and women all over this country  yeah call them call them now because  this guy  is going to be upset that i grew up oh  and the guy runs out of his car  with some i don't even know what this  guy is holding  he chases the one idiot away the guy  goes running  if these people in that video had one  ounce of self-awareness  they would hang it all up the moment  that they said call the police  and they would say they'd throw the  object the guy would turn around they'd  say oh no call the police oak oh right  okay now i understand never mind go home  everybody go home